what you have here it is time now for
CBS morning's deals where we share items
that might help make your day a little
bit better a little bit brighter all
exclusive discounts and during women's
History Month we're going to share some
products from women-owned businesses and
to start shopping now scan the QR code
on your screen or visit cbsdeals.com
lifestyle host Gail bass joins us now I
live by the adage always be charging and
you got something to help with something
yeah that's awesome this is great some
Chargers yes subscribers I love these
this is the power pro go by Limitless
what I love about this is how convenient
they are I'm going to tilt this up a
little bit right here you could see that
this plugs into the wall but you don't
need a cord to go into the cube yes it's
huge do you use your cord to connect it
to your phone it works with most phones
devices laptops what's really great
about it is it's portable as you can see
right there in the video then where do
you put your device you plug it in but
Gail you could also put it on top like
this because it's wireless wireless
charging yes this is a wonderful
wonderful thing to take with you when
you travel a lot doing stories it could
charge your phone two times on the power
it has and it also has a display and
that display shows you how much power
you have left how many Chargers do that
not many that's very cool and what's
what's the price here what are we
talking I love the price on this for
under fifty dollars you want to be
secure and have your phone charged on
very large very long overseas flights if
they don't have a charging station or
it's broke that's happened to me not fun
and a variety of Colors oh yeah I love
the earrings I love this it now this is
women's history month and this is a
women-owned business that we're
featuring this is Rachel glauber which
has been around for quite some time it's
got third generational ownership and
what you have here is affordable luxury
let's just say you don't like a lot of
jewelry and you don't know what to pick
or you love earrings like myself I feel
like I'm not dressed when I dress like
that Vlad I still want to feel feminine
and have my earrings on so I go for
something like this beautiful Hoops
these are designed specifically to be
affordable to be luxuriant and for women
to feel like this is the look that I
want what's the definition of affordable
here affordable here is we have these
for up to 63 off so our prices start at
29.50 yeah and these and it goes to what
I like the ones you have on how much are
those oh the uh these I don't know the
specific one on this one because I I
just grabbed and and didn't look but uh
they go up to 49. 29 to 49 okay 29 to
49. all right all right good price point
this is are these all by the same person
sorry these are all by Rachel these are
all by Rachel Rachel all right now here
I love this this is by re athlete this
is the express this goes on your knee
but it can also go on your calf or your
thigh you can make it work for you now
what are you gonna do I'm gonna stick
your arm in there right okay now this
does compression and heat I have it
upside down sorry about that okay but
right here the controls yeah yeah I want
you to feel the pressure that it puts on
your arm once you do that after all that
bad
yeah and the heat is what do you do this
for you do this for let's say you're
standing on your feet all day you're a
nurse you work in a factory you know
people with knee pain because one in
five Americans has knee pain if they put
this on this gives them the compression
and heat therapy that is recommended and
right here for the price you would get
for a massage you can have this for
yourself every day and it's portable it
has a bag so you can carry it with you
if you know you're going on one of those
long hikes and afterwards you want to
decompress on that rough knee this is
for you it's like compressing yes yes
and then it's hot oh yeah it does get
warm you could set the heat level
because it can get pretty warm some
people want a lot of heat some want a
little yeah I do feel that you can form
it to you and it comes one size fits all
yes it's velcro yes sizable so you can
stretch it out if you've got big guns
baby
yeah less than the price of a massage if
you've got two bad knees you buy two
right yeah yeah I say yes do it go to
cbsdeals.com to get in on these because
people are going to want these Chargers
thank you very much of course we do
partner with all these companies to get
these deals for you if you want to buy
anything you saw today scan that QR code
on your screen or as Gail said head over
to cbsdeals.com to start shopping right
now we'll be right back that's great